Hey ladies it's Joanna here if you're
watching this video because you have
cellulite well here's a good news you're
not alone 90% of women will experience
cellulite sometime in their life yep I
have cellulite myself here are some
facts cellulite has nothing to do with
age it can show up even in young teenage
girls cellulite does not only happen to
overweight people skinny women can have
cellulite as well yup it is true that
cellulite can worsen with age that's
because after the age of 30 we tend to
lose 3 to 5% of muscle mass per decade
and increase in body fat this is
especially noticeable in people who are
inactive smoking can worsen cellulite
cigarette smoke contains a toxic mix of
chemicals that can disrupt the body from
producing collagen making the skin less
elastic and prompting the underlying
layer of fat to show through and finally
there is no permanent solution to
cellulite but what we can do is to learn
to reduce the appearance and to manage
it for life generally cellulite can be
caused by water retention increase in
body fat lack of activity or too much
sitting for blood circulation in the
body and also hormone imbalance so when
our body produces less estrogen
especially as we age it also means
plural circulation decrease in new
collagen production and our other
connective tissues will also start to
breakdown so cellulite is simply a layer
of fat underneath the skin so we tend to
have more noticeable cellulites around
the thighs but stomach love handles and
also triceps that's because as women
those are the areas we tend to carry
more body fat I remember when I was
studying in college before I started
exercising I used to have very
noticeable cellulites
around my upper thighs area it made me
really self-conscious and I would avoid
wearing shorts or even skirt
and whenever I walk I I would always
think if someone was staring at my legs
and what nasty thoughts might be going
through their head and it wasn't nice at
all and even nowadays if I were to just
sit on my butt all day long and do no
physical activity I will start to see my
happy friends appearing around my upper
thighs area so ladies cellulite will be
our best friend for life so we better
start to learn to love it and also
manage it so I want to share with you
five natural ways which has helped me to
reduce my cellulite and they are also
proven methods that can help you the
first method is dry brushing so dry
brushing is a very traditional technique
to improve circulation remove toxins
from the body and in return reduce the
appearance of cellulite so the first
thing you have to do is buy yourself a
body brush made with natural fiber you
want to get a brush with a long handle
to make sure that you can reach every
part of the body and because dry
brushing also re-energize and stimulate
the body we want to do this as part of
our morning routine so dry brush every
day for five to seven minutes before
shower I know it can seem like a long
time for some of you including myself so
while dry brushing what I like to do is
listen to audible my current favorite
listen is the body book by Cameron Diaz
her message is so positive and
empowering in teaching us to create a
healthier and happier you and most
importantly is to love your body so I'm
currently working with audible and you
can get this audiobook for free by going
to audible.com/veritasium a link in my
description box which will direct you to
the site I believe that listening to
positive messages first thing in the
morning has helped me to attract more
good vibes into my life so we want to
gently brush upwards by starting at your
feet and work up towards your heart
bringing the circulation up to the body
so we want to focus on areas with more
for me it will be my upper thighs and
remember to always brush from the left
to right side of the body once you've
done the lower part of your body let's
move on to the mid section so brush your
stomach in a clockwise motion to ensure
good digestion and of course not
forgetting the lower back especially the
love handles area and finally let's
tackle the bingo wings again always
brush up towards the heart so from your
arm to UMP it for quick result you want
to do this every single morning and once
you have reduced the appearance of a
cellulite then reduce it to three times
a week so now that you've just opened up
or your paws anybody treatments you
apply in the shower will be more
effective let's hop into the shower and
enjoy a good coffee scrub having regular
coffee scrub is another proven natural
way to reduce the appearance of
cellulite coffee scrub can improve
circulation remove dead cells regenerate
new healthy cells and make your skin
more firm tight soft and hydrated so to
make your own coffee scrubs you'll need
cut a cup of coffee grounds three
tablespoons of sugar and two tablespoons
of melted coconut oil we want to mix
them together in a jar to form a paste
let's start by wetting your entire body
then apply the mix onto your skin and
always message in circular motions again
focusing on areas with cellulites
rinse it off and have a warm shower you
want to follow this remedy for two to
three times weekly until you have seen
results and you can keep any excess
coffee scrub for future use and the next
really important tip is to drink lots of
water drink at least eight cups or two
liters of water every day to stay
hydrated to
use water retention and also to flush
out any toxins from the body so start
your morning by drinking two glasses of
water on an empty stomach and remember
to continue to drink throughout the day
what I like to do before going to bed
every night is to fill up a bottle with
half a liter of water and when I get up
in the morning the first thing I'll do
is to drink the entire bottle it will
instantly get my digestion going I like
to also add lemon slices into my water
and I will always carry a bottle of
water out with me another really useful
tip is to consume foods with high water
content such as cucumber melons and
leafy greens just by drinking more water
you will start to see your cellulite
reduce it drastically and as a bonus you
will also have clearer looking skin the
next method is ladies increase your
omega-3 intake omega-3 is your secret to
beautiful and younger looking skin it
helps preserve collagen muscle mass and
skin elasticity through its
anti-inflammatory properties so output
that are rich in omega-3s such as salmon
flax seeds chia seeds avocado walnuts
spinach and edamame or for convenience
take fish oil pill on a daily basis it
has actually been proven that adults who
take omega-3 fatty acids supplement on a
daily basis slows down the decline in
muscle mass and the final tip to fight
cellulite is to get active exercising
tones the muscle by reducing fat under
the skin and to replace lost muscle
tissues personally I have seen
tremendous results especially by
including jump based exercises into my
routine if you can't include John based
exercises that's okay the goal is to
work on your entire lower body muscles
from every angle so the front and the
back of your thighs inner and outer
thighs buttocks and hips I've created a
workout playlist just for you to fight
cellulite so be sure to stay active for
at least thirty minutes four to five
times weekly for best results I
cellulite and I know how it can impact
you so I created this video because I
want to help you and other women out
there who might be struggling with
cellulite to learn to manage it for life
ladies it is never too young to start
looking after yourself we deserve the
best okay so apply these tips give time
back to yourself it will avoid junk
foods move constantly avoid alcohol or
smoking and remember that we are all
still very beautiful with cellulite okay
so I just want to thank audible for
supporting my video so be sure to click
on the link in my description box and
get your first audio book for free if
you find this video to be helpful give
it a thumbs up share it with your
girlfriends and be sure to subscribe to
my youtube channel for new videos and do
follow me on my social media pages at
each arena so official and remember to
watch the recommended videos right at
the end all the best
you